Most people have a sibling - in fact, children
in the U.S. today are more likely to grow
up with a brother or sister than with a father.
Now, while a lot of social scientists research
the impact of schools and parenting, little
attention is given to a relationship that
might be even more consequential.
So what do we know about siblings, birth order
and why children from one family grow up to
have very different personalities?
Let’s start with our analysis of the tragic
story of the two most famous brothers in Western
history.
Once upon a time there was a boy named Cain
who received all the love and attention from
both of his parents.
Growing up, the boy knew only one world and
he himself was at its center.
Everyone around him cared only for him and
nothing else.
All that changed when his mother gave birth
to Abel.
Cain should have understood that his parents’
attention now had to be divided between him
and his brother.
This was a revelation he wasn't able to accept
and he became increasingly jealous and sometimes
even violent against his little brother.
Cain, as the first born, naturally looked
up to his father as his role model.
Following convention, the father himself raised
the boy with certain expectations.
It was therefore especially painful for Cain
to see that his father now cared so much for
his younger brother.
Abel, naturally, looked up to his brother
for guidance.
Things were not easy for him either, but unlike
Cain, Abel knew no different.
As the boys grew up, Cain gained a strong
sense of responsibility and, following tradition,
took over the family farm.
Abel, who was free from any obligation, chose
to become a shepherd.
Cain envied his younger brother’s autonomy,
because life as a farmer became increasingly
difficult.
And on the day the brothers were to make a
gift to their father, Cain only brought a
few bundles of dry grass.
Abel, who did well for himself, brought an
entire lamb.
When the father thanked Abel for his generosity,
Cain felt a deep shame.
Overnight his shame turned to hatred of monstrous
proportions and the next day he killed his
own brother.
The first big contribution to the field of
sibling research came from the Austrian psychiatrist
Alfred Adler, and his theory of individual
psychology.
Adler believed that the main motive of human
behavior is our desire for power, partly in
compensation for our feeling of inferiority.
Hence, sibling dynamics play a central role
in family life and personality development
as we grow up.
Adler argued that children who grow up in
the same family experience the family differently.
In particular, sibling rivalry over family
resources influences the development of personality.
As a means of reducing competition, siblings
differentiate, develop different qualities
and choose different interests.
When siblings don’t find their niches, their
relationship can suffer.
The Kellogg brothers hated each other, and
fought in court over who invented Corn Flakes.
The Dasslers competed in business; after one
started Adidas, the other founded Puma.
But many siblings love each other more than
anything.
So what do we know about siblings in general?
Here 6 things science suggests to be true:
First born and single children look up to
their father or mother as role models.
The gap in mental and physical development
between them and their parents may be the
reason that they have, on average, a higher
IQ.
Parents tend to give their first born more
attention and often set higher expectations.
If they can’t live up to those expectations,
they may feel inferior, but on average, they
seem to benefit from their position.
Younger siblings model their development after
their big brothers or sisters.
They have a smaller developmental gap to overcome.
They may also feel that they have less to
prove, but as a result of a lack of parental
attention they develop social anxiety more
often.
On average, Relationships between brothers
are more conflicted.
Relationships between sisters are more intimate.
Siblings spend more time together than they
spend with their parents — younger siblings
even twice as much.
Children with siblings are physically more
active and less often obese.
They are often happier too.
Some studies suggest that they develop social
skills faster than children from only-child
families, but the research isn’t conclusive.
Sibling attachment seems to be a strong predictor
of well-being — sometimes more important
than paternal attachment.
This also means that if one is bullying the
other, it can affect them for life.
One Swedish study of people aged 80 years
found that while closeness to friends did
little for total life satisfaction, feeling
close with a sibling did a lot.
For those of you struggling with a difficult
sibling, Adler had the following advice: “A
simple rule in dealing with those who are
hard to get along with is to remember that
this person is striving to assert his superiority;
and you must deal with him from that point
of view.”
This and all other Sprouts' videos are licensed
under the Creative Commons.
That means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms, online courses
or
to start projects - and today, thousands already
do!
To learn how it works and download this video
without Ads or background music, checkout
our website or read the description below.
If you want to support our mission and help
change education
visit our Patreon - that's patreon.com/sprouts.